[Music]
george martin comes from humble origins
he was born in 1948 in bayern new jersey
his father was a dock worker and the
family lived in a low-income housing
project by the water
i do think some of my desire to write
and some of my desire to read was
motivated by
the limits of the life that i led we
didn't have much money to spend
we didn't own a car my school was on
fifth street
i walked to it and that was for all
intents and purposes that was my world
my world was
five blocks long from an early age
george was aware of a lost
fortune on his mother's side of the
family the brady family
who once owned a successful construction
business a dock
and a grand house all lost in the great
depression of 1929.
but i had to walk past that house every
day on my way from
the projects on first street to 5th
street and
it's like well that used to be our dock
that used to be
our house now we don't have a house we
don't have a yard
but i had always had the sense of yeah
i'm
poor but i come from like royalty
or i come from greatness that somehow
was
destroyed by the depression by corrupt
politicians
by things like that so maybe that gives
me a little of the
uh emotional temperament to understand
somebody like daenerys targaryen
what is it you want my birthright the
seven kingdoms of westeros
i'm sorry little princess i am not your
little princess
i am daenerys stormborn of the blood of
old valyria
and i will take what is mine with fire
and blood i will take it
other kids had cars and they got out of
town um
you know they took summer vacations down
the shore in
in the mountains we couldn't afford to
do any of that we just
stayed in the same old apartment in the
summer and i dreamed of being
on other planets and living in other
times and i was a lonely kid i was the
kid with his nose in the book
um i was the last kid picked for games
or
things like that i didn't you know
sports i was was no good at sports
so i spent a lot of time uh you know
sitting reading
reading comic book reading a science
fiction book
most of my initial exposure to many of
the
great works of english literature was
through the classics illustrated comic
books whether it was
you know the time machine and wore the
worlds to the best catholics illustrated
or
shakespeare they did shakespeare you
know hamlet as a comic book
but then i discovered superman and
batman and they were much cooler so i
was
reading all the all the superhero comic
books so i think it was
really comic books that made me
interested in
reading and in stories and
heroes as a schoolboy george martin was
writing superhero and science fiction
stories for himself
his friends and for comic fanzines he
still has some of the figurines which
inspired those stories
these are some of my first characters
most of these are aliens
made in the united states in the 1950s
and sold in
five and dime stores they have no
stories so
i made up stories for them and this is
some of my earliest writing
but i decided that these were gang of
space pirates
this guy was from mars jarn
i decided his name was he was the chief
pirate he was the head of the pirates
and this guy was supposedly from orion i
couldn't figure out this weapon he was
holding
it looked like a drill to me this weird
little weapon
so i decided he was the pirate torturer
he would use that drill to drill into
your knees or your head and get you to
spill your secrets i was a
bloodthirsty little kid even then but
the black and white comic book world of
aliens and monsters superheroes and
villains collided with reality
when george went to college in illinois
in 1968 to study journalism
this was the height of the vietnam war
and george had to rethink his worldview
i'd come from bayonne and you know
baylen was blue-collar and very
patriotic
and you know the united states could do
no wrong
and and uh etc but college was an
education for me
i remember being assigned to do a paper
to research the vietnam war which before
that i
just thought about well it's we're in
another war and we're helping
poor people defend themselves against
evil communist aggression and i
actually researched a war and the role
of the french and
you know the complexity and the rigged
elections and you know
suddenly it didn't look at all so
clear-cut to me anymore and
i gradually uh got radicalized i suppose
you would say while still a student
george sold his first story which
appeared in the science fiction magazine
galaxy
in 1971. the hero
is a tale of a battle-weary soldier
fighting on a distant planet
who wants to retire and return to earth
that was definitely an anti-war story
and an anti-uh
militarization story it was actually
triggered by people coming back from
vietnam particularly
green rays and all that who've been
trained to respond violently to any
any kind of threat and and they had a
hard time turning this
off in civilian life what if you have a
you have someone who's a soldier like
that in the future
and he's you know he's this killing
machine he's his highly decorated
killing machine
and now he wants to go back to civilian
life how do you make him
not a killing machine a couple years
later when
i was called up to be drafted i applied
for conscientious objective status one
of the supporting documents i submitted
was that story which
was like a couple years before so it it
clearly showed
anti-military and anti-war
sentiments you know two years before my
application and and
perhaps gave my application a little
more credence so my draft board did give
me
conscious objective status despite
taking an anti-war stance over vietnam
george martinez constantly returned to
warfare as a theme in his fiction
war is an important subject it's there
it's all through
human history i mean you go back and
and you read history i've studied
history all my life i've read history
what is history history is war history
is the history of war you know the
romans versus the carthaginians the the
greeks versus the persians the
wars of the italian city-states during
the renaissance the 100 years war the
you know the american revolution the
british revolution the french revolution
uh
it's all wars and and violence it's
it's the most important subject
look at me stannis is a killer
the lannisters are killers your father
was a killer
your brother is a killer
your sons will be killer someday
no elders built by killers
so you better get used to looking at
them
game of thrones is set during a bloody
civil war
and it portrays war in all its brutality
epic fantasy is universally about wars i
mean tolkien
and uh even before talking er edison the
heart of epic fantasy
always seems to be some great war or
another and to some sense i
i think i'm in dialogue as i write about
war with
other fantasy who've gone before me and
and
even my contemporaries but unlike most
writers of epic fantasy
martin depicts war as horrific and
largely futile
rather than heroic it's a complicated
issue here
i'm not a complete pacifist if you
believe in war under any circumstances
then you have to say you'd
fight in world war ii i come on the
nazis were
the closest thing that the human race
has ever reached to orcs
um if the if the nazis had not existed
and we invented them for a fantasy novel
people would say
oh you come on you're going over the top
this is ridiculous you know they
they're cooking people in ovens they
wear all black uniforms they have skulls
on their
on their hats come on this is too much
but that's the reality of the situation
but if you look past world war ii i mean
look at world war one
my god what a colossal waste of
millions of human lives what was world
war one all about
why did anyone fight in world war one
you know why did
why did anyone fight in
the war of jenkins ear the war of the
three henrys
you'd have a surrender and all this
bloodshed i understand
the country would be at peace and life
would be just under the righteous hand
of good king joffrey
you're going to kill jeffrey the gods
give me strength and then what
i don't know we'll go back to winterfell
i have no desire to sit in the iron so
who will
i don't know you're fighting to
overthrow a king and yet you have no
plan for what comes after first we have
to win the war
you go back and you look at these
thousands of years of wars and
what caused them and you know
most of the time it just doesn't seem
worth it
george's route to epic fantasy was
through a different literary genre
in the 1970s he was building his career
as a science fiction writer
this was a time when the apollo moon
landings were turning science fiction
into science fact when i was really
young i wanted to be an astronaut
and go to the moon and walk on mars
i used to wonder would i live long
enough to see men walk on the moon
and then by the time i was in college i
saw a man walk on the moon but i never
dreamed
that i would see men stop walking on the
moon
it was great you know but it was also
sometimes when a dream comes true it's
not as cool as the dream
martin started to have success with
short stories which used space travel
and life on other planets as a way of
exploring themes of existential
loneliness
he traveled to science fiction
conventions around the country
and shared ideas with fellow writers
like his friend lisa tuttle
george is in that kind of cohort
i guess of writers who were serious
about what they were doing
loved science fiction loved comics and
movies
and making up stories set in outer space
and thinking about things that didn't
happen in in this world
but at the same time they were putting
real emotion into it one of the
big voices in those days was harlan
ellison harlan was always talking about
the necessity of
writing from the gut of bleeding onto
the page of
you know digging deep and and you know
getting too powerful emotional material
that was the stuff and that
i took that to heart i said to myself
i need to write some some stories that
expose my vulnerabilities that that hurt
in some sense that
that where i'm i'm getting at some
truths is the way i
i see and experience the world martin
started to win awards for his stories
and went on to write a series of
successful novels
which reworked popular genres he did not
write the same book twice
he would write a huge thick
beautiful space opera set on a dying
planet
and then suddenly you're you're
reading a riverboat novel
um and suddenly there's vampires
happening
and he's a different kind of writer and
it became obvious
that george was a writer who wanted to
try everything
i think genre is
just a matter of furniture the furniture
doesn't matter the human heart can
be in conflict with itself in a story
that takes place in a castle and that
has dragons in it
and it can happen on a spaceship 10 000
years
in the future or it can happen in a
suburban setting or in the streets of
bao new jersey
to my mind it always comes back to the
human heart and conflict with itself
what faulkner said that is the only
thing worth writing about
and that's the thing i always try to
write about regardless of what uh what
the setting is
but when george's fourth novel the
armageddon rag was a commercial failure
he was forced to find work as a writer
in television my not career as a
novelist appeared to be over after that
book i couldn't sell my fifth
novel in 1986 he secured a job on the
relaunched classic science fiction
series
the twilight zone writing short stories
and novels is a
lonely experience going out to hollywood
uh
you know suddenly you're you're part of
a staff of writers and and you're
taking coffee breaks with them and
you're saying here's the stuff i'm
writing and they're telling you what
they're writing and you're kicking
around ideas and
you have a secretary to make coffee for
you and you watch dailies together of
the show that's
uh that that you know somebody wrote
yesterday and
you're visiting a set and visiting with
actors and of course you're having
meetings with the network and the studio
and and uh you're going to premieres and
you're part of this larger world working
as a writer in hollywood was lucrative
but george found that writing for
television had creative limitations
you write science fiction fantasy you
don't have to worry about budget
you're you know you can put anything you
want on the page and
the reader's imagination supplies to
rest but when i was
writing for twilight zone and beauty and
the beast and i was constantly getting
notes you know george we we love this
this is terrific but
it's five times our budget so can you
please cut three of these matte
paintings and
gosh you have 27 characters in this
thing could we have six
and uh this big client battle at the end
where two armies of a hundred thousand
people are fighting could that be a duel
between the hero and the villains that
would be good
in one episode of the twilight zone
loosely based on the king arthur legend
george was told he could either have
stonehenge or horses
but not both it's easy to see how his
vision
was restricted by the budget
stop it you old goat the great side
about working for hollywood television
is you are part of a collaborative
medium the bad side
you're part of a collaborative medium
and all these other people have their
own ideas
they want to change this they want to
change that you should rewrite it the
sponsor doesn't like it
the network doesn't like it sensors say
this standards and practices
and that kind of stuff can drive you
crazy and uh
and did drive me crazy after a certain
amount of time you know i could take it
for a while but at the end it
wore me down